étranger
[Musique]
ils allaient faire cinq implants à
l'origine
la deuxième visite quand le
traitement était sur le point de commencer euh ils
m'ont fait attendre près de trois heures à la
clinique et quand finalement le médecin m'a
vu j'étais prêt pour la procédure
ils m'ont renvoyé et deux traducteurs
sont venus et ils me disent que maintenant nous
devons retirer toutes vos dents parce que
vous vous êtes tellement détérioré au cours des
quatre derniers mois et nous devons faire 16
implants
et il y a eu un gros choc sur mon système
[Musique]
et j'ai enlevé mon masque et mon mari l'a
regardé il fait tout ce qu'ils
t'ont fait ton visage est tout enfoncé les dents
ne ressemblent en rien à la façon dont tu avais l'habitude
de regarder
et j'avais des trous sous ma gencive
comme de gros trous  parce que c'était si
mal fait que c'était incroyable
[Musique]
étrangère
[Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique]
pour les implants
pour les facettes et les couronnes
pas pour les sensations pas pour
les traitements de canal pas pour le nettoyage en profondeur ou
la pollution
[Musique]
merci
étranger
[Musique]